quick stretch little snack and here we  go  sonic i love that you want to help make  a difference  if you're being reckless don't worry  nobody's gonna get hurt  pretending to be batman blue justice  trademark pending  you're still just a kid  trust me there will come a moment when  your powers will be needed  but you don't choose that moment that  moment chooses you i just got goosebumps  wait a second did you steal that from  oprah  papa's got a brand new stash  since i've been gone i've discovered the  source of ultimate power  that sounds big  it's been on my vision board for years  hope i'm not too late  i'm sorry who are you names tails okay  this is what we're gonna do step one  light taunting step two i have no idea  that wasn't too bad  today's forecast calls for a 100  chance of adventure  [Music]  return to sender  face it you're never going to get my  power  do i look like i need your power  where  are my manners sonic meet knuckles  [Music]  [Music]